very very sad you
know you're watching Al jazer we break
into programming to bring you some
breaking news we're hearing from
American Media uh who are now reporting
that the US has started retaliatory
strikes for the deaths of three soldiers
that took place in Jordan uh earlier
this week in fact on Sunday so what we
know so far is that there are reports
that the US is bombing parts of Eastern
Syria uh let's bring in Z joining us
from Lebanon in Beirut with more on this
developing story Zena what are you
hearing about what's going on in eastern
Syria we
understand well what you mentioned the
American Media report that the
retaliation the the US retaliation for
the killing of the soldiers begun but
there's still no confirmation from the
Pentagon what we have been hearing from
uh sources on the ground really are
conflicting reports uh uh mentioning air
strikes a series of air
strikes now dour it wouldn't be
surprising because dour this is in the
east of it borders Iraq can this this
province is considered to be a
stronghold groups that are B by Iran
they control the Border cross
Syria and Iraq a very location so if
these go after these groups then
definitely their aour will be among the
targets so conflicting reports now what
we understand um you know for for for
the this wouldn't be really the first
time if indeed this this is the US
military carrying out carrying out these
strikes uh targeting this area in fact
since the Gaza the war on Gaza since um
Iranian back groups started to Target US
troops in Syria and Iraq there have been
um you know retaliatory strikes by by
the US military in this area but but the
biggest question right now is whether or
not indeed if this is uh the
US to the killing of the will be will
this be enough to deter these groups who
have said that they will not stop
targeting American troops um despite the
eminent retaliation for the time being
we are hearing reports of air strikes in
E Syria uh an area where Iranian back
groups Iranian personnel as well Iranian
faciliity they're all based in this area
that border region but still no
information from
the okay Zena we'll let you go for now
uh we'll come back to you a little bit
later we do apologize for the connection
uh the audio issues we were having with
Zena but we'll bring in um Al jaaz
senior political analyst mwan bishara to
weigh in on all of this so mwan um as
Zena was just saying look we still
haven't had confirmation from the
Pentagon that this indeed is the us but
this is what American Media is reporting
right now that air strikes have taken
place in particular for what we know so
far is in data Zur in eastern Syria your
thoughts on this well I tell you I think
it's expected right uh regardless of uh
of our uh attempts at scratching our
heads the past half an hour just trying
to figure out who's who uh who's
responsible for the bombing where the
bombing are taking place why uh certain
American sources deny it and others
confirm it and so on so forth but if you
look at the uh literature and the
Declarations statements and everything
else been coming out the past five or
six days clearly the Biden
Administration have made its decision to
retaliate to the attack on Northern
Jordan and it clearly had a number of
potential
targets uh the Republicans in Washington
have encouraged the Biden Administration
to bomb Iran proper Biden said that I
don't want a war with Iran and the
administration was presumably looking
for alternative uh options other than
bombing Iran itself so so you can say
that it had four options option number
one is to bomb the Iranian military
targets conventional military targets
even nuclear installation so on so forth
it discounted that the other option was
to bomb the the Iranian revolutionary
guard bases
clearly it discounted that option as
well uh there was a there was a
challenge that whether it will bomb
those Iranian Republicans guards and it
will be faced with the their defenses
and apparently they didn't really go for
that option and the third option was to
bomb kah's or the Hezbollah brigades
bases in Iraq for the time being we we
don't hear of reports of any bombings
within Iraq so in fact if if big if if
those reports are correct Washington or
the Biden Administration has chosen the
lwh hanging Target the lwh hanging fruit
among all of that and CH the target is
in the failed state of Syria so what
would be the the aim of that then so
according to reports that uh that looked
at what are the value for some of those
targets apparently kah in eastern Syria
is quite concentrated in it terms of its
bases and most important for the
American for forces is that that's where
they fly out the drones let's remember
that the attack at the American base on
Northern Jordan or in the Jordan Syrian
border was carried out by a drone it was
the first time that an American Soldier
died by bombing from the air in a number
of decades this is a whole new chapter
for American strategy and for American
defense system and so on so forth so the
first Target apparently apparently was
the one that was looked at during the
week where Wasing were you know various
evaluations from Washington were saying
that the the most important strategic
Target in terms of air
retaliation to the attack in Jordan
would be to attack the base from which
those drones are flown and that is in
the eastern uh Border in Syria Marana in
the bigger picture and putting this into
context does this have the potential to
uh to escalate the situation and ignite
the region I mean just a few days ago
the Secretary of Defense the US
Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin he
said that the US will not tolerate
attacks on American troops but at the
same time he said this is a dangerous
moment in the Middle
East exactly I mean you know when you
when you listen to what they're saying
in Washington they're basically arguing
that there's absolutely no way America
the world superpower and the Middle East
greatest power was not going to
retaliate for the killing of three of
its
soldiers and not just that that this
comes after reportedly something between
150 and 160 times where uh American
forces in Iraq Syria Yemen and other
places or targets have been attacked so
it was almost uh you know accepted as a
fact that America was going to retaliate
anyway
so within this condition that America
was going to retaliate America
apparently chose the most de
escalatory
escalation so any number of those
options I just uh I just uh underlined
to you earlier about con whether they
will attack conventional forces in Iran
Iran Republican guards or
Iranian supported groups in Iraq it
actually chose not to attack any one of
them for the time being they chose as I
said the lwh hanging uh Targets in Syria
a failed State basically where America
could function it actually already has
bases there and it doesn't feel that it
would upset or doesn't care if it upsets
the regime as it would if it upset the
presidency in Iraq or the regime in Iran
in Syria it's a much easier Target for
the United States to that now let's all
remember that back in
2018 uh Trump or the Trump presidency
also chose to bomb within Syria after
the chemical attacks back then so Syria
is a much easier Target for the United
States than Iraq and Iran and clearly
they've chosen the place where
reportedly that's where kah flew its
drone that killed the American soldiers
in Iraq now we should remember and
remind our viewers around the world is
that the Americans have warned once and
again the past few days that this is
part of longer sustained campaign that
this is not a
oneoff in fact their retaliation is
going to be sustained and in a number of
because they claimed that kah itself did
not attack just once it in fact attacked
a number of times Marone stand by for
just a second because we're going to
bring in correspondent Roslin Jordan
who's joining us from uh the US Ros what
are you hearing on your end